bis heute
[Musik]
das gebaren russlands das macht vielen
angst die finnen und auch die schweden
wollen jetzt in die nato und russland
lehnt das natürlich ab die türkei die
blockiert den beitritt unsere kollegin
antonia jamin ist dann die russisch
finnischen grenze gereist dort lebt man
vom grenzverkehr der jetzt eingestellt
ist
jahrzehntelang herrscht hier reges
treiben an der finnisch russischen
grenze leiten 100 kilometer so lange ist
die grenze zwischen finnland und
russland
jahrzehntelang war finden neutral die
russen kamen hierher auf diese seite
nach finnland um einzukaufen verwandte
zu treffen oder sogar zu arbeiten wenn
man hier weiter fährt kommt man direkt
nach sankt petersburg mit der autobahn
aber jetzt weil pandemie weil krieg und
auch weil finnland der nato beitreten
möchte wie man hier sehen kann fast kein
einziges auto der krieg und der
angestrebten nato-beitritt finanz lassen
den grenzen kehrt zum erliegen kommen
die grenzgemeinden haben die
zusammenarbeit schon früher ausgesetzt
wir haben eng kooperiert
grenzübergreifend korbach jetzt mit
russland aber das wurde von uns
ausgesetzt eine woche nach dem krieg
nach der russischen invasion der ukraine
finnland und schweden haben offiziell
die aufnahme in die nato beantragt klar
dass das nicht auf russische zustimmung
trifft
auch die türkei sperrt sich präsident
erdogan lehnt den nato beitritt der
beiden länder ab die finnen vertrauen
ihrer regierung vertrauen ihrer
premierministerin st anna maria eine
mutige frau die sich gegen putin stellt
wir vertrauen seiner marin und wir
denken sie ist eine tolle an
inzwischen sind fast 60 prozent der
bevölkerung für einen nato-beitritt
finnlands vor dem krieg gab es nicht mal
30 prozent zustimmung wir haben ein
bisschen angst
und deswegen nach da ist das beste
lösung allein sein und
uns lassen niemand will etwas passiert
bekommen wir hilfe doch was bedeutet das
für die finnen die vom grenzverkehr vom
tourismus leben la plata ist eine
grenzstadt zweitbeliebtestes ziel von
russen in finnland 1,8 millionen kommen
sonst jedes jahr und trotz der
wirtschaftlichen abhängigkeit trotz der
unmittelbaren geografischen nähe
befinden zeigen solidarität mit der
ukraine
wir sind stark und wir stehen gemeinsam
hier in finnland hinter der ukraine
wir tun alles was möglich ist um ukraine
zu unterstützen ukraine ist frieling
trieben europa
[Musik]